you
[Music]
hey folks happy Wednesday Eric and Nick
back together which can only really mean
one thing I feel like when I am with
certain people it usually means that
we're playing a certain game and so as
the title would say we're playing pub G
on Xbox one with the update now we're in
a match we decided we're in the circle
already so we would just kind of keep
going am I taking this gun from you
ah it's not letting me drop this red dot
so that's fine I'll take EA K over this
stupid shotgun whoa that's fine it's
fine I like the double spray-and-pray
here but yeah so there's a bunch of
updates mainly one of them being that in
the opening area you're not kind of like
put together with everyone anymore it's
more like PC right yep worrier kind of
like separated players players have been
separated so that kind of allows the
optimization the beginning to be a
little bit better it's a little less
laggy although I haven't had any
problems but then we just played for a
couple minutes and it seemed to be
fluctuating we were kind of teleporting
around um so I mean there's still some
there's definitely still some
improvements that the Xbox version needs
but I will say that my friends and I we
play most weekends on squads and there's
been a significant drop in people
crashing which is good
um cui turb the gameplay audio just a
little bit sure we're putting duos for
the first time cuz Nick seems to not
want to do the bets anymore what's up MB
gamer know each other now dude I liked
hazing you I know you like that but
alright let's move to the next building
next door cuz i looted this alright all
right let's see that each game you will
scope II I already I shouldn't have
burned through my oh I hear a car I do
too I don't know if these guys do you
hear that
yeah where are you selling this building
hmm are you selling this building yeah
yeah I'm downstairs okay do you think
they just drove past cuz I don't hear
them anymore
or I don't hear I know I don't really
hear them to be honest okay so just me
I'm crazy cuz I thought maybe the
gameplay audio is low but I don't yeah
I'll give you more gameplay
I can't tell like we're on different
headset so you got to tell me if it's
enough or not
well I'm teleporting you are I was a
little bit it's fine okay all right
let's uh what are we doing here
let's go through here let's go to the
next one all right
I'm teleporting - I shouldn't have used
my boosts I really shouldn't have it's
been well I am yeah that's being a
little monkey right now I wonder do you
think it's our it could be we're on the
non-corporate II internet which we could
switch off here in a second after this
yeah after this match we can switch um
people have been here okay cuz it does
for those your footsteps or do you hear
someone upstairs okay right it sounded
more like would then tile but okay you
tell me yeah it's you okay okay
why don't we are where are we good spot
yeah I was gonna say we should know
kills chilling like villains so do you
want to keep looting because we can get
I mean like if we can loot some more
great cuz we I have no Busan and only
one first a kid alright let's go ready
yo Tay
do you prefer foreign I approach zero
says Cole Slayton to be honest I've been
watching a lot more fortnight lately
compared to Pope G um I can see
arguments for both I'm gonna close the
store I will say this right now and I
don't know if my friends are in the chat
right now they're gonna be very upset to
hear this I'm starting to really fall in
love a fortnight and I think the reason
why I can watch for at night more is
because there's less of these scenarios
right where you're kind of like walking
around looting yeah
playing safer I feel like in fortnight
you're kind of thrust into the action
sooner for better or for worse however
you want to look at that
but there's more my internet ad D
basically kicks in where like for my
just feeds that ad D more than pub G I
used to watch a lot of pub G but now I
find myself watching more for tonight
but for tonight's a harder harder game
in some ways to get into in my opinion
I've heard a gunshot
getting near I don't know only because
this double tap maybe it's us maybe our
voices are really high this is I don't
know people uncheck and tell us how's
this
please take the mic out of your mouth it
sounds gross how about that how about
that so good thanks Marie Frost so yeah
I've been noticing that I've been
watching more fortnight but building a
fortnight is definitely harder I hear
that this is painkiller right there oh
there's been killer you pick it up no no
I not have one back fax where's the
painkiller it's in that room right there
oh nice I said don't this t-shirt yes
Angus scope I only have one two times or
sorry hollow yeah I'm hollow where are
those coming from because I heard that
but yeah I really like for tonight I'm
definitely not good at it yet I need to
work I'm moving I need to work on my
building skills especially on PC yeah
it's kind of loud okay let me um both of
us chat or just one of us right you're
upstairs there's some seven six to hear
yeah actually I have seven six two I can
drop you I got 60 I think I dropped you
some there's a ton up here now I'm
focusing on Nick senses voices lure yeah
as time allows as clutch god all right
just tell me which one of us is too loud
and all kind of this is how I normally
talk - from loud right now no I think
you're good I think I'm loud despite me
being loud when it's come to place for
who knows new map is not out on console
yet nope no new maps I think that right
right now the first thing that pub G
needs to do let's uh let's move across
the street
let's get some action I think that the
first thing pub she needs to do is get
the new map into Xbox I think that's the
first thing they need to do to start oh
sorry to start competing with fortnight
well that yeah and then I also think
that they need to start introducing some
new modes whether that's squads of eight
or they because I know we're gonna
probably be seen a 20 V 20 V 20 those
doors are all open right there I forget
are you on are you on Xbox one
we are all on Xbox one axis gunfire
that's close yeah I think that guy just
killed someone - so okay I'm going to
the roof to see if I can spot them fully
he doesn't spawn up
that's real close to inside it's inside
one of these buildings I think and he
can probably see me so I go back
let's see how do I switch the rate of
fire again yeah it's this little side
button here so a little uh what is it
left left D pad left d-pad thank you my
brain is mush when I play this game well
you're talking to a guy that barely
plays but uh more aggressive please yeah
those bullets I guess so
I'm looking for with a compensative
Piper up top oh I'm I saw one of them I
think I saw one of them going to the
building to our right like but like one
let's see ones too like three buildings
down where are you look immune oh we got
to move okay let's just let's just move
to the next circle one maybe we'll run
into him on the way out all right uh
Lauren are you see him no no they were
like north of us though yeah they're
like I so if I saw correctly they're
about four buildings down from here give
or take but I don't know you tell me we
wait for where should we go
well we gotta go so let's hop this fence
here and then if we keep pushing down we
might run into somebody and then I have
my car back at that compound where you
first came okay let's run through little
cliff part of the updates is just off to
my a lot of optimization there's like
better water sound there's a better
loading in terms of like the first area
because you're split up from other
players now you're not all on the one
same area and also I think they took the
guns out of the first opening area he's
not wearing shoes so whoever said take
your shoes off it decreases your
footsteps
I might have shoes on I don't care how's
the frame rate frame rate it's been fine
so far but we haven't fought or shot
anyone yet I will say the other day we
had a we had a fair amount of people in
the final circle and it was lagging like
crazy you said that was recently right
that was this weekend someone just asked
how is it do you think it's playable
more playable than it was day one Oh a
thousand percent ass out I'm like pretty
happy with where it is right now to be
honest
also the 1x performance is definitely
you can see the difference yeah
also let me see what else is there other
gameplay changes include is included
RLS or is it less damage taken from
objects such as rocks and trees and
uneven terrain on top of that squad
member colors should now be more visible
well you can use the right stick to
rotate your character at the
customization menu terms of bug fixes
water sound effects were apparently
busted but they should show oh where we
getting shot from I'm not sure I think
it's back to our left it's yeah it's to
our left someone keep moving
look at me not dude it is impossible
scoped - oh yeah out of a car of a car
it's like impossible for me on PC and so
there on the hill no oh they might be
well we're gonna smoke past where
they're at so hopefully I don't have a
car where are we getting out of they got
a they got a move because they got your
almost tough ten let's go I do know
kills top ten let's go oh yeah they're
on top of the hill they're on top of the
home okay are we chilling in these
buildings what are we doing you tell me
when to get out
watch oh hello yeah Jeff Fager you gotta
go baby they're shooting us you gotta
make a decision I don't like being shot
at okay good good terrible an exit are
we going what that frag and then I don't
all I was a red dot so I don't think I
can scope him all I have is a hollow
they're probably way up on that mountain
yeah I think I see him peeking up there
all my strats are like four night strats
they're not gonna work it was weird
because all my port initial for time
strats we're pub he sure yeah yeah
that's a guy you see him oh you know I
don't have a I don't have a scope but at
least I spooked him a little bit all
right let's uh which building and even
the bigger one I'm next to you I was he
like at the top of the hill all right
whatever we should watch our left to his
people from hospital could be rolling
down on us there also could be people
just camping here which I
freaking hate yeah well it's part of the
doors are open are they camping I hate
campers Oh scar I love camping yes time
to hitch that tent you know times eights
go but they said they rarely play yeah I
don't know just like plays a little bit
I don't I don't play that you want to
know no you can have it I'll take
whatever take it okay I'll drop you some
five six I hear a car do you hear a car
yep I do uh yeah they're moving are they
going like past though yeah they're
moving this close to the center oh shoot
we gotta move again okay I just put a x
eights copy though anyone up here that
would really be irritating no okay
oh but I do need that don't get sniped
uh get sniped I'll get sniped what are
you doing I wanted to attachment all
right let's move back down to the car
[Music]
watch out though yeah these guys these
guys rolled down to the car and they're
just camping our car I don't know I dude
but the car wasn't in a great spot
necessarily already dropped we're
getting in the car in the in the car in
the backseat uber uber please take me to
the circle yes yes mini-14 but get the
scopes which the m16 those from spazzy
new thank you cab mother the stairs do
you think this game is dying on it in
all honesty as Daniel Huerta
gube there is a camera appliance right
there we're just like out it's a chat
Daniel I don't know I think that right
now for tonight's winning but it's only
because fortnight is free and it's more
accessible to more people I feel like
also it's on both consoles and PC where
as pub jeez only on you know Xbox and PC
so in just in terms of like the ability
for people to play
I would assume there's probably more
people playing for tonight what was new
in the updates I mentioned a bunch of
the this stuff it's nothing major
necessarily there's a drop but we
probably don't wanted to probably
someone grabbing that don't worry about
that
so close though no no do you want to win
or do you want to drop unless you think
that drops gonna help us win but all I
have is one boost which is not good into
the woods right now but there doesn't
seem like there's much foliage or cuz no
foliage really there's some fluff
oh I don't know where they're at
I don't see them they're probably those
houses all right we're on the outskirts
we're chillin on the outskirts there's
the drop is like in the middle of the
field there's some foliage here whatever
we'll be outside of the circle though
right I see guys running up there what
to the Rob this is a horrible circle man
so what you want to hop in those
buildings yeah this circle sucks
there's definitely be homies here though
all right I hear fire to our right get
ready
guns blazing full auto full auto I'm
going in which building the big one did
you see anyone nope doors are open
though I'm gonna shut the doors behind
me though all right young boy I feel
like someone's got to be going for the
drop right Oh 1,000% damn circles
changed again oh really
damn we got to get in there then later
huh all right you think I can snipe the
drop I'm not gonna be able to so good
luck to you sir late times how much oh
well I see people where's he going
though where you going where you going
where you going are you upstairs yeah
I'm on the roof which is not a good move
but come on where you going where you
going where you going this is riveting
he's ready
Oh Oh what up homie uh-oh
pop someone's ooo you see the flash hide
up to the yellow house we're up here
right in that window nope
I kind of see it but now you're blocking
the door and I can't get inside bolt pop
them once damn good come on
better get them headshots dog just
remember a circle later okay yep where
did the dude you shot that was running
towards us go though probably just to
the first building then hid behind the
wall or he's behind that little
there man I don't I'll I humps my humps
my lovely lady yeah look at that freakin
drop man damn Britain the middle real
juicy
ooh this that some guy just ooze e -
guys dank meme 35 seconds so let's move
to the we'll have to crawl a little bit
crawl it gonna get hairy it go get hairy
okay where we going we got to go into
the field isn't that it's in there a guy
like right out there though robably we
gotta move over all right
I'll fall on you checking boost oh man
oh man oh man boost so I'm gonna boost
way down is it just holds be the boost I
mean - yeah whatever you know what I
mean all right I'm in this bush trying
to see if I see any much oh [ __ ] what
was that oh oh that behind us probably
watch grenades are flying Oh God I'm
boosting I'll give it f I figure I'm
never gonna get to boost again chat I'm
scared I'm scared look at us laying in
the table I hate this circle oh guy guy
guy guy guy we're guy right here I'm not
in the circle right now I'm crawling -
you see these guys I have no coverage
dude are they behind the rock because
it's data right here oh we are behind us
oh god no no no I suck I should have
turned on Otto I'm an idiot you he got
you too yeah bad bad I don't I didn't
hit that one guy that was bad I turned
it off Otto cuz I was like oh let me pop
him real quick and they just [ __ ]
rush me
she excuse my life alright top ten from
doing nothing
top ten all right let's go to spicy
let's get spicy let's just go to the
schoolyard and and die but kill some
hopefully clear some people shoot that
was that was shitty on my part no III
whiffed dude I didn't hit that guy once
but I I had that thing where I really
don't like the what do I have to start -
sorry I don't like the thing where I
don't scope I wish I could just turn off
the other like the the crosshair one I
want the scope scope like a deicing I
want eighty I clearly just 80s I don't
like the that controller aim though yeah
I probably would have hit him if I had a
mouse keyboard but he probably hit me
sooner so I don't know it's it's
debatable yeah I mean yeah excuse I mean
I do MB gamer I want to play on PC but
like this game is so it's it's been
doing quite well for Xbox guys play on
PC well no the whole purpose was for the
update no I mean obviously
oh so this is that opening area there's
less people obviously guns are not there
anymore
yep less laggy play destiny - man I wish
that game is more dead than anything
right now and I'm of Destiny guy I mean
thanks the original super pony whoa I
think that we're going to school the
controls yeah we go school I think that
controls can be better I think that like
just the way controls are mapped it
could be better and I kind of wish that
there was like the opportunity I guess
that's true that a young Hiroshi to just
like remap the buttons I guess I could
do that so school right where they'll
there's school or poaching do you want
man no let's go school
let's get hairy alright tell me when
you're tell me when you're rejecting is
moving the right stick harder than a
mouse it's harder for precise aiming
tell me when you want to get out force a
means to flee ready now now okay
ejecting ejecting alright let's get some
let's get some some kills babies at this
school right there the bigger building I
think it is right
mvgame er I think my goal my next goal
is to get at least medial like somewhat
good have you see anyone around us Oh
what thousand percent would love to see
you guys play for it for another tilted
tires this is essentially like the
tilted towers before I got a guy to my
lunch xbox are you playing on xbox one X
both of us oh there's some guy that's
beating me to the top oh my god oh this
jerk just picked everything up oh I just
fell off oh you're funny like my knees
dude are you hurt oh yeah I'm hurt not
that bad though it is more like a scrape
are you serious there's nothing in the
gymnasium oh my god nothing's loading in
there's nothing there was nothing in the
gym dude dude we're in trouble
we're oh we are 100% in trouble I have
found it no loot I found a two-type
scope oh that's great you know I got
pistol I got pistol this guy's got me
coming down I need a gun I need a gun I
need a gun not attachments oh yes
what you get what you get 16 do it do it
do it they got no oh I got Tommy gun
where is it a pizza cutter you see
anybody no I'm just trying to reload my
pizza cutter is the piece of cutter
always auto yes always okay I have a
first aid kit if you need it
later I don't know where they are I
don't either I'm afraid so am i someone
just do it smoke smoke is it near you
yeah it's in the back for the school I
think I'm coming to the front now I hear
action somewhere
sounds like the roof it's the roof
should we go roof I don't know I guess
so
all right if you want to roll it to the
roof here I'll sacrifice myself oh shoot
there's some pop in there right here I
don't see him I thought it sounded like
the roof maybe they're back back back of
the school she was a dead body there
we're here well like a bomb went down
here let's go oh you think he dropped
down in the theater I looted most of the
stuff in here in theory yeah I took the
the top oh there's a I didn't grab that
energy drink though or that helmet so
I'm gonna grab that this guy this is the
least amount of people I've ever seen in
school yeah most people don't like
school name I only have 30 rounds of
five five six that's the only thing any
a backpack for the outside real bad
how far is this circle oh well we're in
we're in the dead center nice okay
dude I've never seen the looks of school
with such a little leet I've never seen
the school with such checking checking a
second floor I kind of did
are you did there's nothing he might
have went to those apartments right the
ones to the other side because there's a
lot of loot over there yeah yeah there's
nothing here dude you don't think I've
gone in a full circle personally and
unless there's stuff that's just really
dark and I can't see it which is
possible all right oh all right gunfire
back in the school but like there's this
wing pool area or whatever are you going
there I don't know want me to go there
I'm going up to the roof I'm just gonna
do it
Yolo okay tell you how it goes I checked
out oh yeah he's in there he's in there
is he where is he was in there he's
coming down the stairs coming down
stairs
got him got him got a gun nice all right
so this is always he go down right away
yeah he's dead I killed him did he go
down though right away or did he crawl
you guys I'm 16 now I killed him I
finished him off oh I'm just trying to
figure out where's buddy is his buddy
might be at the apartments cuz I don't
think he's still here are those your
footsteps coming against me I'm coming
in are you upstairs I'm in the swimming
pool he has m16 with no ammo is it the
m416 or the it is the m16a4
I only have 30 rounds that's the only
thing okay not pick up his backpack I
did it I got a little one here no no no
he's got level two there I drop back
junk city loot chat oh wait did you grab
his backpack maybe you didn't have a
backpack and it just looked like he had
a backpack uh I don't know but the no
shoes thing man I am I'm on a fellow in
shape notes type these dorks good try
good luck you can if you want to go
ahead Cup yeah come and give us all
right let's move somewhere else okay
where should we go
I know I thought you said we're in the
circle I'm still like trying to our dead
center but I need loot
yeah I know I'm missing someone I don't
have a backpack still Oh seriously
there's a backpack in this little thing
outside oh yeah I level three helmet
though or was that little not have a
vest ran all the way around the pool -
no I did not just pistols and stuff
sorry where's the backpack
it's it's here we're gonna have to go
outside alright so yeah come this way we
can go at this window oh great can't we
go out this window no we can't go out
that window lit oh that car yep
it's coming towards us towards us
yep yep yep they're right here they're
right here at Holiday I think they're
about to hop out yep they are they are
where'd they go
there's the car where are they
the cars right here maybe hits maybe
it's his partner coming to avenge em
don't know [ __ ] I hate this is there
only one entrance this Way's I don't
know no no there's a couple I hear him
oh there's a level-one helmet here this
whole time
idiot this is a bad place for me to be
right yeah oh yeah I hear it too
might be coming upstairs a level two
baby oh I shot him a couple times
all right where is he down below you
don't yeah he's down here I'm outta ammo
though which is the problem well I mean
I have a little bit he's down oh I see
him I see him I see him yeah he's on the
backside under the stairs you know what
I'm talking about like my side under the
stairs he's anything yeah he's chilling
under there I'm gonna try to flank him I
don't know what her name I'm gonna oh he
might I walk down the stairs oh oh shoot
you might come up behind us I'll go this
way - are you going from that side I
think he bailed yeah
I think he build this a backpack right
here though let's get one down here
where's that you like and you might go
get his car and his bail
I guess so sure cuz we gotta go get loot
somewhere I don't think this guy's got
it I didn't grab that backpack though
that's right down there good cover you
oh I think I see it okay got it
what are we going stealing his car oh
he's buys car he's buys car okay
we didn't scan I flank I'm on the other
side yeah yeah are you kidding me
he's coming right toward you this is a
joke oh my god there's two of them
there's two of them okay okay okay shoot
I might say my sanity oh my god
[Applause]
I have no ammo i hella miss I lit that
guy up though
I got no ammo come to me shoot is he
coming this way I don't know the other
guys on the backside yeah I shot the one
guy he's here I'm dead
yeah no I got him I got him we gotta go
hey hold on okay yeah can I revive you
well he's coming he's coming
just just leave me I'm good I'm good
there is gone yeah I got no ammo he says
hold X I am [ __ ] holding X uh just
press it present once okay yeah woody
nice aim I lit him okay he dead he dead
he dead we got him we got waits okay
it's okay
Nicole I am NOT playing at first you
need first aid you need a first date I
need anything um could I drop I'm gonna
go check there I just dropped first date
I just shot for safety okay I just loot
- he's got first date I'm gonna take
this first aid okay and he's got garbage
though the rest
this guy's garbage I drop first day
behind you though okay thanks this guy's
got garbage dog yeah what is going on
yeah they do have garbage all I got
shotgun shells I don't have too much
family left either I have like twenty
three five five six let's go get their
car did you met up though
you [ __ ] up yeah I met up we can get
their car this way yeah sorry that you
guys didn't get to see the well you saw
that one kill yeah they saw it I saw it
cuz I was there alright cuz that guy's
an idiot like hey get him get him get me
get me are you trying to revive man you
trying to revive where's Dilara Dillard
the update mainly is like quality of
life stuff so the early part of the
loading stuff is better in terms of like
because you're not all on the same map
anymore there's no guns there anymore
there's better water sounds it's better
optimization I think you take less
damage from like weird terrain rocks
trees let's see what else is there I'm
trying to look at some gum we're gonna
suck in City okay so tell me tell me
what I need to hop out game DVR is now
supported for automatic recording I
guess we're hopping out
yeah yeah we're are we in the circle
still oh yeah yeah yeah level 2 back
--pack okay you can take it if you don't
know work out all right I'm coming to
you it's in that little Hut little Hut
dang man I got to level two scopes and I
got no way you want my m16
no I I mean I have one I've seen ammo oh
you're not that ammo got it okay all
right I'm gonna just Yolo it and head
down into the city here people have
probably been here oh it's outside the
circle a little bit good good good
that'll dis that'll discourage people
from coming here you're probably low on
boosts here I only have one boost I have
none I'm literally my inventory right
now is sad mine isn't too much better to
be honest but I've never been since I
don't play this game that much ends like
I don't think I'm doing everything right
so we did we but we survived us school
so that was good shoe I mean I guess I
have three kills which is not too shabby
that's good I I still I can't I lit that
one guy out with pretty much a full a
full like round of full clip of the m16
and then I shot Gundam and he was still
alive I was like yeah unarmed makes you
run faster not bare feet bare feet is
just to kind of help not make as much
noise is what some people say which I'm
not convinced I'm not either there's
like no loot in here that or has been
looted you think maybe those guys came
from here I don't think so all the
circle is behind yes oh shoot I just
went in the water oh oh the water sound
if you guys want to hear that I just
walked through damn there is nothing
here there's no way they'd shut all
these doors behind them that is so
tedious never no man some people are
sticklers for closing doors over there I
found an energy drink just good do you
need vest or anything
local to backpack footsteps are way too
loud after the update says rice King ad
I wouldn't know
do you need five five six yes yeah
there's a
I'll leave one five five six I picked up
a mini to just pick just pick up the all
the mo okay and then you can we can
separate it you're gonna hold Y what if
there was just someone camping in here
and that's why all these doors are shut
howdy campers oh my god Papa G give me a
lute remind me to drop you a five five
six later this is insane oh thanks a pan
hey man pan could save your life
che I shouldn't be in this water a
shotgun the water sucks it just goes you
know try to get back out here see if I
can alright so uh the performance
definitely it's it's not on par with I
didn't mean it's definitely not on par
with PCC
0:03 backpack double energy drink I'll
get you a dry found to sound to boost I
have a ton of 762 but holds whoops level
two helmets how are we doing on the
circle over on the outskirts yeah we're
good though we're right on the edge
sure why not we'll look cool water Oh
baby
eske asked do you want to show your
stream sniping ability I was it's a
stream sniping which is fun thanks
everyone for tuning in appreciate it
we're checking out the Xbox one update
we're actually playing co-op which is
why I'm not reading the chat as much as
I used to so sorry some guy said you
miss a car 98 who me yeah that's what
Nova groom said because the shots I pick
up best someone said there's a scar I'm
not sure I'm not watching your screen
there was a that was a shotgun that was
on a car okay I don't know dude I'm just
reading chat bro yes I am well that's
not a pan well boost
oh nothing I hate walking through these
houses the water this slows you down yes
yes the shock oh boy we go please fast I
need one oh no I already had one here
Oh God DMF s2i there's another best -
over here alright okay oh my god know
what swimming through the there yeah
just trying to get through to use a pain
in the butt
hi insights I can I can make my way to
you to you oh wait no you need the best
though I can't yeah it's gonna help you
there I'm gonna go loot somewhere else
then actually this might be a little too
of us - oh no it's a backpack my bed oh
yeah I definitely can drop you that my
pizza cutter gun oh those circles coming
oh it is yep okay taking damage as we
speak oh good
is it though I don't like quickly check
the roof here in the home Vale
are we running back to school then ah
our car shouldn't be in the circle maybe
over here I'm running towards the circle
okay worth it level two just don't like
the damage I'm taking okay alright I'm
kind jump jump down jump through this
tree and I'm gonna hide in that hut
where the yeah I'll be there in a second
I'm off the boost
evening the circle is getting a lot
smaller by the way extendo mag for what
they are
now for the my SKS now now I only have a
RN all right all right cool
you need five six five five six all
right yes if you have any I just dropped
it on the ground all 33 let me move stub
I'm boosting up to it's in this room the
five five six whole area sits back on
the school huh oh did you grab that five
or six alright I have not that much ammo
then which is fine yeah I only have 36
rounds I'm gonna have to keep everything
on single shall we go on though let's go
sir woods in there I've no scopes you
there sir I get says that he'll all
right - I write or write north of 185
181 like the patch notes I'll link the
patch notes in a second a tech scope
diving board Oh someone's saying a 1050
is better than Xbox 1x I don't know
about that we'd have to test that that'd
be interesting
I really like my 1x I want a field here
we're going to those buildings yeah the
the beige looking ones in front you yeah
I have crap loot I need to kill someone
take their loot so do I I'm low on five
five six can you stream for tonight
after this game probably not today but
we will be doing more for tonight stuff
down the road my goal is to get a
fortnight xbox stream at some point cuz
trying to egg my friends on if they're
on right now after watching James Henry
and Chris calling you boys out let's
play some fortnight alright these doors
are open okay I used my first aid - just
now so I don't have that either how does
the mini shoot can I hold it down if I
had to I know it's sniper Oh
it's just like well then I'm burst
firing I guess I guess I actually have
to aim yeah I hate the burst to be
honest it's fine because it sprays up
pretty hard so I think behind you I
think they might be in this building now
doors open I figured these it look like
all the doors were shut I was like
that's a telltale sign of there's
nothing in here I'm just going up to the
roof here see if I see anyone
this door is also open yeah it's all
open
monson it--my peakmi you guys think it's
all looted dude level to helmet do you
need level to helmet Gatlin yeah go on
oh shoot they definitely left there's a
box here so someone's dead body no no
there's uh there's a care package it
just dropped or no no there there's one
up on the hill which probably means they
like salt and just went oh we're gonna
grab them just come on it
this building is shy go check so I go
check the package oh you want to see if
they didn't take notes no there's no way
they didn't okay I have a question for
chat those of you who play pub gee oh
we're gonna have to move are we going
let's just get moving
we'll just start heading towards the
woods here I'm at 115 for those use play
pub G when you have an m16 or I'm gonna
just check packets real quick if you
have an m16 or you have a scar do you
guys put the vertical foregrip or that
like flat grip that I have on right now
right there like which one you guys
think is better they're dead bodies by
the package just an SKS on the ground
there's a dead body here with some five
five six okay and a scar you take five
five six I'll be fine
yellow where is the 500 it's on the
block yeah it's in the
I think it was two guys at that day what
do you guys like better the the
longed-for grip or the whatever the
stock looking looking one
I took a triangular shape what's it
called on I remember yeah it is thirty
friends are y'all going to play five
high five as Jackson fits yeah
definitely going to do that state people
are saying vertical verticals better
that's baking Snipes just shocked so
once that angle do deal yeah oh that's
right Dylan says vertical yeah I was
under the impression vertical was the
better one but then I was watching some
pro streamers and I saw them using the
angled grip and I was like wait what
so that's why I figured I'd ask you guys
to see how is there no one up on this
hill just sniping down on us cuz that's
what I would be doing what I have to do
again to go unarmed why hold on why I
did that
oh you're playing first-person oh I
didn't mean to do that
do you want to hop out of it yeah I get
out oh you press R what is it okay our
next points are be there you go Oh
guys guys guys guys here or north of us
wait here write it look a compound here
we go okay this guy's going in here and
let's hold this I mean this horrible
terrible aiming wall next time take some
shots when you're sure where are they
right here he's all I see him he doesn't
know where I am
oh sorry stream he's behind the house
yep he's behind there I'm trying to I'm
trying to flank him careful careful
yep I know is I'm just peeking them and
see if I can get them to peek so you can
come on got him got him got him damn I
should have you on the frickin screen no
I play better without having to it oh
god I shot you oh god I know my fault
do you take damage huh yeah my bed oh
[ __ ] oh right outside the circle does he
have any loot Oh
his energy drinks you need it first aid
oh you know first to hit whoa you pick
out the first aid yeah oh no I picked up
I'm using one god when you shot me you
scared the crap out of me you want this
five five six or contacts take take take
I have 46 shots I'm gonna do some really
slow like boosting and stuff oh god I'm
so sorry
all right there guys right nearby but I
want the scars up boost up sixteen alive
look alive
all right pushing this hill like just
like edging it yeah where's the circle
oh my god the circle is like so tiny
should we spread out a little bit
there's I've heared gunfire to the right
I love it I'm staying with you staying
with you cuz you're better than me
always got her in front of me
oh really see ghillie suits ghillie suit
you see him no no no he's right in front
of me ghillie suits ready 1 2 3 lighting
him up he's dead
nice well there's another guy right here
he's laying in the ground yes where he's
about to take me out it killed him he
was dead he's prone instead he says
Dead's dead
I got it I got a heal he's on he's on
he's dead bodies on me yep coming in oh
I should take that ghillie suit what am
i doing oh don't get psyched here oh
[ __ ] he had a little three helmet take
whatever you need Oh baby hidden awm who
do whatever dude if you want the aw no
I'm not gonna snipe I'm definitely not
gonna snipe I know better
I like the SKS better to be honest I
know what chats about to say but circles
moving circling okay I didn't even have
trying to look at that guy's loot I am
out of like five five six though oh
shoot no no that's fine just it's fine
okay there's there's some Rando guns
floating in the air right here dude I'm
taking it's the mad damage right now
behind us don't worry about that right
now dude the circles like gonna kill me
probably shooting in front of us there
in front of us just make it through the
start dude I'm I might die to the circle
I should have boosted I boost it and I'm
still gonna die I think I think I'm
gonna do right I think I'm gonna die I
think wanted to [ __ ] we played that
wrong I didn't know I wasn't
III really bad at looking at the circle
sorry that's my bad we shouldn't we
should have just killed those guys and
ran I don't know how much time we had
well the circles were tiny they're a
damn where is this region mean I don't
care about regions North America duh all
right all right back
yeah and he does not enough loot I mean
at that point didn't matter maybe I
shouldn't have boosted I sure just ran
damn
we just ran my bad
is that KevJumba nah it's not kept job I
wasn't watching the circle to be honest
yeah I'm gonna need you to monitor that
I know that stuff like I'm I'm already
like deer in headlights and just trying
to like deal with uh deal with those
guys it was like we were so lucky to see
the ghillie suit guy cuz like we just
happen to roll up behind him and then
his friend
what's his friend saw that he died he
didn't know where we were but like i
luckily saw his helmet through like the
grass and yeah i was killed I'm with I'm
with der mondo here he's like yeah you
really can't take the time to loot at
the end gotta look for what you need
early on and that's why I didn't take
the awm cuz I heard the SKS and I was
like all right like I could loot but
even if I had stopped the loot then I
would haven't dead even earlier than I
was so not bad ID I think I had six
kills how many did you have like one or
two at least I know you finished at
least a couple now but that gives you
I'm just gonna okay that's good that
gives you the oh if I knock down and you
get there okay yeah I got played better
man this is just embarrassing as usual
it's the pressure the string gets to me
baby I had that one guy I rolled up on
him early and I was like I'm gonna kill
him and I thought I had my dude I was
really close to the edge of the circle
just now if I had just gotten to the
edge I could have lived like I always
like at this much life and I thought I
got there because it didn't kill me
right away and I was like right on the
on the outskirt of it but yo ah oops you
oh yeah what's our what's our current
record looking like right now what have
we come in the past to do you think that
was top-10 - it was yeah I'm pretty sure
there's a circle is tiny where we going
let's go let's go military military all
right even though even though I'm gonna
call it right now tell me when I jump
I'm gonna call right now this circle is
going to end somewhere in the North yeah
now we're jumping all right jumping Oh
number nine number five okay that's
pretty good
thanks a son
yeah we were close like if we could have
just found a way to outrun the circle
and at like that's the worst feeling I
feel like it's like you got all the way
there the circle is the worst is the
worst thing at all times
period it's Lambo man I'm going to land
at that little um pound off to the left
okay I'm gonna drop is anyone around
this I am yeah yeah for sure for sure
because uh I see one guy above me okay
there's one guy really far oh my god am
I left I'm dropping in to this compound
where there's like three buildings okay
that's where a lot of people drop so get
ready to go oh yeah yeah you got like
five people on you we've got to throw
hands then boy I'll quick run through
here try to grab a gun then just get
over there somebody behind me just go
upstairs come on pick it up
oh my god put that on oh no what is up
with the picking up stuff right now I
got pizza damn already yeah hot damn
yeah the picking up is a little laggy
right yeah is it lagging for you yeah
yeah that's why I thought uh I'm sixteen
a four and I have an Uzi m16a4 oh shoot
out of a backpack okay okay - I can't
pick it up
oh come on oh is that a little three
backpack a little - that's fine whatever
oh that's a little three asking you
shower see baby have you checked the
circle at all
oh it is down here put the circle yeah
it's down here I'm going upstairs this
could be a mistake yeah I don't forget
people probably landed on the roof yep I
see someone all that Molotov just lagged
the crap out of my screen that guy had
nothing though I think he's running i
looted all of the downstairs there's
definitely a guy in this building
downstairs first floor I can come come
now Oh baby it's good loot over here
okay I'll just come to you because this
definitely it's something hot I don't
know if that guy ran or not though
because he did not have a gun I hit him
at least twice and others them there's a
mini here if you want it five five six
I'll just keep the pizza cutter in the
UK I call it the pizza cutter I know I
thought you guys called it the pizza
cutter I called the om4 16 - oh let's
switch out of this yeah was about to say
what do you have oh god there's a guy
there's there's multiple guys out here
they're all outside all right this guy's
running toward your building - jump jump
this guy's running towards your building
I don't know where you want though I
gotta stay buying this wall well okay
this guy's running oh okay that guy's
all the leads up here yeah a roof over
there I'm coming to you there is
definitely no loot in downstairs from
what I can recall all right those guys
are on the roof next to you right where
you're going so I'm downstairs I mean I
haven't gone upstairs at all okay the
mini was open god that's me the minis in
that room - you're right this one yeah
yeah should be behind the door
no no no the room across in the room
across this room I need a backpack I
don't have a helmet either yeah I do
have a little three backpack though okay
I will see ah can't go in that room I
want to see if I can see the roof from
here you can kind of see it I know
they're over there
I hate burst three games in a row three
bursts do you want to a K yeah yeah yeah
where's it they K drop it I'll drop my
my a K oh no no if I have an m4 here I
dropped it I dropped it I dropped it you
need do you need the amla to I know I
have the ammo okay I'm gonna go grab the
pizza cutter okay or whatever that thing
is called the tommy gun I got I don't
know I think it's called the idea that
jump-scare by Eric yeah you got me good
okay okay all right we're in the circle
okay see anybody know so we go
downstairs sure I mean there was shotgun
[ __ ] happening
what do you wanna go I have no backpack
I have no helmet I'll shoot if we go
back to that warehouse that I started in
there's stuff over there backpacks and
stuff okay oh we can't go out this way
can we go out this window yeah we can't
okay ready watching sure I went out the
back door but all right let's go these
warehouses oh god don't snipe me
verses on them succeeding is the highest
EVs in the game I think I heard for one
burst
yeah I'm not shocked by that yeah what
was that OS 12 K SKS right here if you
want something I want snipe take some
selfies you backpack
nice yeah any helmet
oh yeah I need a helmet to shoot I
should be just looking for a level one
uh I'm gonna take this a mana I'm going
to a building that's diagonal from here
okay coming that's the one I started
there's no helmet in there there might
be I don't know I rushed through to get
to me yeah
there could be people here cuz I would
assume that they would cycle from those
over here y'all what up chat how's it
gone
tell me when we need to move Circle was
oh he are suppress okay you got to be
the guy to monitor the we're good
circles good oh yeah I'm gonna get
conscious ever at this line level to
backpack you have a level two right I
have a little three actually nice
here's a little one helmet oh nice
what's that thing next to a ball cap
yeah
oh shoot this one killer picking the
pink Euler up
they any peeps in here they're being
real quiet okay sick oh yeah we need
that you have that's right
love one yeah level one only down here
up a hair bike it's probably people
leaving the island or rolling in it
sounds like leaving probably dune buggy
dune buggy probably leave in yeah
leaving well we got four timer yeah do
you want four times Dan no no no unless
you have an ex Ron no but I don't I
don't know no you keep you keep dude I
trust me I don't know not gonna use it
properly
I'll find one this is kind of crazy it's
found one yet yes I need a helmet or we
need to leave soon I guess I don't know
find a helmet somewhere else all right
let's see we can go to these silos here
if you want silos okay sure
I don't know where this circle is going
to and I hear gunfire behind us yeah
separate did you see if that car kept
going or yeah they kept going a couple
they did okay I was like they could or
at least are going up that way to loot
maybe or something
I love the many bacon Snipes I I love
the many the many might be one of my
favorite snipers I love the way it
sounds I love the way it shoots and I
love that I think they looted this one
to the next one
how does circle end in once inside like
one of these silence on time is pretty
whacked a way out is the X is the coop
23rd I believe the shooter I thought
they were trying to like get out of
prison maybe it's not a shooter but I
think guns are involved I know they're
they're breaking out of prison it looks
awesome
I'm really excited but I am very excited
for one game in one game only we're on
the One X PlayStation dude see if these
baby I am so freakin fired ah who is
that helmet yep you need it yes uh well
you can take it if you want little -
I'll take a level one I don't care I am
so freakin jazzed up for see if thieves
it's not even funny I can't wait what
are we going Nick let's chill in the
silo and see where the circle goes up
here oh here's something
trying to get on this hill to get sight
Oh what was that did they just blow up
you might have oh my god check their
leaves right here yeah it's right in
front of us but I didn't see anyone die
though okay let's be careful just be
careful I'm gonna wrap around from the
bottom to your right alright there's a
there's a dead dead body there's a box
yeah you might just be dead that is
doomed buggy from earlier you might want
to check his box I'll try to first laid
energy some five five six level to
helmet level to vest I'll take a level
two but there's a mini there's a mini
and there's more Oh two times or take
the two times I just want that level two
vests and a quick-draw oh you want the
best I don't know it's just take it if
you just take that's fine it's fine it's
fine the drop is uh
not that far from this you see it where
it's like north or 345 let's go let's
get let's get let's get some let's get
some juicy action oh yes an m16
I'll tell you what you go for the box
I'm gonna go up on this hill and snipe
down dude he needs more more guns too
then I just drop you get the four times
here on accident Oh No yeah whatever
oh no it landed in like a cow's compound
so there might have been people in their
loot in chat you see anyone I will be
behind you shortly so but I'm not gonna
move on until you get here I am moving
have you guys checked out a way out no
but they there will be some stuff going
up at some point from a way out oh [ __ ]
nobody alright I'm running all right do
it
how are we looking in circle-wise
probably okay all checks are College
there is definitely someone in this
window just watching me work all is to
our right diagonal to our right okay so
I don't know how quick we have to be oh
Gore's a baby I drop all this take the
three best so I can take your two best
okay yep oh can I not I'm gonna drop
that cuz we don't you know do you not
need your two times I just put it on the
ground so I could he's in the he's near
the gas gas tank guessing gas tank
give me 205 205 or 215 205 oh yeah I see
him I see him okay can I plane come or
is he staring at me still he's still at
215 he's trying to run she's running too
you know he's going in the building the
house I'm trying to flank him trying to
sneak it behind them I think he's in the
house you think so no no he's right
there he's right in that window he was
right in that window right next to you
let's see if I can look down the hall
here I think he flipped it he's behind
us now
he's right there where I Sturken a down
were you that dog were you at yeah he's
in there and we're he's give me a number
he's inside this building somewhere I
just I saw mover oh yeah I see him I see
him
170 all right 170 he's right here he's
right on the other side that wall if I
shoot I shouldn't you see me on the
other side yeah he's right on the other
side do you want me to move in if you
want to okay I'm gonna try to oh I see
him right here it's nice nice nice bro
let's go take his loot and get out of
here bro he's got a med kit okay I'll
take the med kit oh you actually you go
first cuz I got the care package so I
don't need to make it I just need the
the first aid you can have this no no
I'm good
discuss to generous man which couple
generous guys you should take his
painkillers oh I did to you I did all
right uh I think all right cool where do
you want to go Chi - oh shoot we gotta
go oh we're okay we're good I thought it
was like on the other side let's um
this circle is gonna end up on the other
side of the bridge I think I want a
vehicle but we got to get moving so
let's just go he has eight times by the
way I have one okay cool yeah uh I try
to find you
that's celebration by neck I know it
feels it feels good to finally get a
kill in front of you all let me remind
you all it for those who are here the
law the last time Tay and I stream this
game not in particular not not Xbox but
PC Pub gee we didn't get one kill
remember that yeah I do but we were
entertaining AF man we were entertaining
AF but we got no kills
damn so bad I got six that last game so
that I don't know I told you I'd be
better at console though for these stuff
not grabbing for that suppressor for the
grows Oh makes me sad you know way back
when I may have said it even on stream
and subconsciously not noticed I used to
call it the Gores ax because I thought
it was Geor not G let's call it the
gyoza there's a mod sticker
dude motorcycle motorcycle I'm behind
you so it's gonna take me a second to
see it okay no no a motorcycle for
Austin for us okay okay do we know do we
need to I think so cuz I think the
circle is gonna end up on the other side
of the well you know wait wait here is
there a car I feel safer in a car right
now oh yeah yeah there is dossie yes sir
dude I got the pub Jean the pub
keystream curse 1000% it's all up in
here all up in here what are we doing
Nick let's see taking the car
yep damn this is an ugly circle a lot of
water imply here a lot of water
that's right fry fry bread if you're not
first you last get in there this is a
thing where you can like pop painkillers
and stuff now right well I'm not turning
you can okay so tell me when you want to
take them let me just get us along let
me get us out of here okay I'm just
gonna keep trying while you're doing it
just to see how long up almost like a
game within a game I need to get us
across all right go ahead take him
taking them yeah I'm taking I'm taking
them yeah one second got got oh no all
right we'll get it across the bridge but
get ready because there could be Bridge
camper I hear I hear okay fine oh god
what is this chat
I guess we're fighting our way out of
this right oh god they are bridge
camping
are we not fighting our way out of this
where are we going I don't know I don't
think I can make it through there okay
that's fine what are we doing then are
we swimming our way out oh man
shoot can we swim our way there oh my
god I just swing my way there right I
don't know what to do we could swim our
way there alright then I'll bring us to
the area where the shortest amount of
swim
distances dude we gotta go though right
or when does the circle clip minute 16
okay we got Oh Mike Chad a time to swim
they want us to fight him okay fine
all right get up on a hill then get a
saint let's pull up here and let's light
down on them all right I don't wanna
probably painkiller gonna kind of pop
look at this pink look at this stuff
right here it's all glitching out oh I
see one laying down
oh no this guy's gonna loop this guy
yeah yeah where they at
yeah yeah yeah come on baby let's go
where they at now there they're down
there they're camping they're camping
the bridge so they're just they're just
laying near the cars and stuff I wonder
oh man I freakin frags we could have
gone over there and frag the UH
he's laying there laying down near the
cars yeah yeah just like the cars up he
went behind it cuz I killed one of them
can we not just like light the cars up
on fire if you have enough ammo I don't
fortunately there was someone shooting
to our right see literally all there
running across the field of 105 east 105
they're trying to run across a bridge
right now ones really far ones like near
the bridge lead them shots leave them
shots oh god he's got a he's got a
sniper oh boy he's got a sniper who the
other guy the guy that was farther
my aim is paralyzed so I see him I see
him he's running now
good thing I have a red dot and like no
MMO left this is why I don't like the
Xbox version just for the all right
let's let's get the cards go oh shoot
alright I'm coming to you I'm coming but
don't we have to break through the other
cars we're gonna have to we don't have
choice to circle zones here we break
through the cars with the dossier Yolo
can we just take one of their cars what
are we doing here oh I got it back I got
a backup have a really bad feeling about
this chat oh me too
why don't we just get out and take one
of the the Humvees oh my god I'm stuck
which one do you want I don't know
though I don't know if we can get out
alright then jump over it oh wait orange
I see okay didn't get it I'm trying go
ahead go ahead go ahead
ah we're good I don't know trying to
live what if they're bridge camping on
this side okay let's just go where we
got worried
Oh were you in the circle right now by
the way I know I know dude there's a
tiny circle we're gas station no no I
don't know you tell me you you have a
better gauge of this game than I do
oh there's just two people in front of
us 55 always the awesome I see him I see
him
I'm trying to turn there legit look
trying to light us up Oh getting out I'm
gonna spill Lunas building I have no
ammo by the way what do you need what do
you need five five six right
how does soon oh I dropped all the five
five six it's fine it's fine I will deal
I don't need a gun there's seven six
damn okay alright where these homies
that they're still down there
oh my god what is this going on what
I'm gonna let you show up there yeah
yeah come on buddy come on buddy you
know LP key I'm gonna cross the way so
I'm not behind you okay
just really close the doors behind me so
I can hear him alright so there's guys
up on the beach they're two guys in the
beach they're using the oh man I should
just drop you all that's fine it's fine
it's fine
the two guys on the beach they're gonna
use the water time to switch to the
vector to the vector
I don't have a choice dude I need ammo
oh my gosh oh I should teal uh I'm gonna
just use it that's a bad idea
oh my god use the first aid
I don't let me use the first date oh I'm
an idiot I'm an idiot
get him chat alright so I know there's
two guys in the B she's at him peek in a
little bit oh it is what are we doing
I'm gonna play headshot oh I hear a car
no a motorcycle once I go just jumped
out you know he's like 150 he's going up
the hill they're getting lit oh that guy
across the street yeah yeah I see the
guy across the street there's two guys
and I had that back off now back off you
got that guy behind him I knocked his
buddy okay I missed it it's okay it's
you know he's gonna Rev him shoot should
I push him no no no no no a car behind
us somewhere yeah dominant guy coming
behind you he's in a little hot there
oh that was terrible man he's coming to
you he's coming to you I know he is he's
downstairs downstairs
yeah come up I'm rushing him from the
other end I'm coming in yep he's still
downstairs he's still downstairs she's
in the yeah yeah yeah in the stairway
he's in the bathroom bathroom pooping
his pants there's a lot of people for
this little circle did you get him no
he's still down here it he's never left
he's just chillin in this bathroom okay
there's literally in that bathroom ready
I don't sure do you see him oh sorry Oh
what is that what was that I don't know
someone else was be here is he up here
not upstairs I I went upstairs I heard
gunfire ah me too but this windows not
broken I really need this loot they're
upstairs they're upstairs with me no now
you tell me they tell me cut the sarado
save me they're gonna bribe this other
guy no no the wood chipper this is why I
love this game there's a single fire -
you ever make it so yeah I'm good I'm
good I'm good I'll met up real quick I
love this gay baby I love it I love it I
didn't get to leave that guy's body by
the way dude when I squeal you know it's
going down boys Oh Oh is there seventeen
people live this circles so small all
right Oh loot is all years it has
nothing what about the other guy this
guy I don't know damn the freakin gore's
ax or grows up see I knew I was in
cultural thing at some point was clutch
baby I where the rest of these homies at
for us to kill you check this
I did I'm drinking a boost right now I'm
gonna take both goofs I think possibly
maybe not save one I don't know why I'm
looting that there's some five six here
I took it or just some okay I'm gonna
take some yeah I want a four times each
none of these hats at four times there
there could be that the guy the guy at
the very downstairs could have it I'm
gonna check the bathroom right now
except for we should not be do we need
to move shouldn't be doing this but just
what is that what is the gorgeous take
on the front the court what is that is
it a flash hider or something for oh my
God we're in the next circle are we
let's go oh I see people do you need a
see people almost stool I'm closing the
doors make them that you yep oh is this
the oh this is the genie in five five
six no no no I'm good I have 77 rounds
I'm gonna have 185 I'm using as a sniper
anyway where they at
they're out here you shooting yeah
they're out in the field they're way out
there can you give me a number 235
they're running through the field
they're out in the open and I cannot hit
them for [ __ ] I'm just gonna let them
they're so far away from us that oh oh
baby but so the circles moved oh yeah it
is it's north of us huh let's not move
until 30 seconds okay I wonder if there
have been homies in these buildings like
next to us and the left are we where are
we trying to get to later just so I know
all right you see these guys on the
field no I don't this guy's creep in
there ah none of those guys had four
time scopes nope they don't even know
you see these guys right here
we're right here oh I see him kind of
they're really far from me
come on Nick
oh my help somebody else I'm gonna go
grab a new helmet Oh guys stole my kill
it's fine
grab me a new helmet okay okay I took my
kill bro why the only reason I survived
that battle upstairs was because of the
level three vest
Oh baby this guy not have a helmet what
the SH I may have shut it off him all
right look at this I swapped helmets
right here what are we doing what's the
plan here ah run run forward do we have
five seconds but yeah I know we're close
enough all right let's push up let's
push up to where all right I'm gonna
need the water Terry's or the yeah don't
worry I'm gonna figure it out the trees
trees trees trees trees what if they're
just in the goddamn house oh you see the
guy straight ahead yeah you 85 I was
sniping him earlier I'm going to the
trees I just don't have a choice
he's still there I think he's trying to
find you there's a guide am i right
where are these people Oh what I'm not
in the circle dude this is insane how
small the circle is for ten people
there's a guy in here the blue Hut 335
well I'm getting shot I'm getting shot
I'm dead
Oh building he's in the building uh 200
he's on the balcony it's why I don't
worry about me I'm sorry I don't know I
think it's because it was one behind I'm
completely sure you can you hide can you
hide behind this tree I'm completely
surrounded though there's people he's on
your right there's guy on your right -
oh my god Nick come on baby
Nick there's a guy that's gonna be
behind you in the building in the red
building you're gonna get shopping how
I'm gonna get shot from all sides can
you heal here yeah ammo
no no I was like why are you fire even
firing dude ah 12:20 I think that was
again are you talking about me ma Morgan
I thought I was calling out he was going
out calling out numbers it's like it's
the it's the pick it's the panic at the
end we're like I don't know I get so it
is what it is I mean like pretty good
though I mean we got a lot of top tens
cuz all things considered that was a
weird circle but that guy the guy in the
red building that killed me was like in
a very optimal spot because that house
where he was was still in the circle
yeah so he could have just chilled there
chilled I'm all day and I I had no
choice but to push out because we had
nowhere to go that's why I was like we
go to the red building where where does
the circle go and like how does the
circle like cater to like what you have
yeah so yeah quick just so you guys know
so the Xbox one updates been out for a
couple days now it's got that pre match
starting locations are better now
they're more optimized there's no guns
in the air weapons in that area anymore
game DVR now supporter for automatic
recording better water sound I think
there's lower damage take it from
objects throughout the world such as
rocks trees there's a bunch of other bug
fixes and stuff but that was a quick
breakdown Nick we do these pretty much
when there's a at least decent sized
update for Xbox and we know there's a
lot of people that play they're the top
of PC maybe maybe when the map comes out
desert but everyone anyway but maybe
most people are tomorrow there's that
weird crazy 20 be 20 be 20 be 20 be 20 a
bank but we're also streaming for
National Women's Day tomorrow just so
you guys know so or International
Women's Day I think is what it is the
proper terminology but come back at 11
some of our want to celebrate the women
that work in our office you know they
work hard and it's a great day to
appreciate that so come in tomorrow we
might try maybe do that for it now
I don't know we'll see after but yeah
thanks everyone for tuning in we almost
got there Nick you got four girls I got
one kill that time we were close host a
couple times we never had it we never
had a bad we never had a bad round um
we're just so yeah cool
hi friends thanks everyone peace see you
guys